The General Data Protection Regulation or GDPR as you've likely heard it called.
It goes into effect on May 25th and it could affect you,...
...no matter where you are or where you live.
How?
Let's answer some questions.
So, what is GDPR?
It tightens Europe's already strict laws...
...about what companies can do with people's data.
It gets you more control over how your data is collected and used,...
...and forces companies to justify everything that they do with it.
How will it affect you?
One way is that you will often have to opt in...
...to letting a company use your data.
This means fewer pre-ticked boxes...
...and firms are compelled to use clear and simple language.
Why is GDPR a concern for non-EU countries?
Because many businesses collect or use EU residence data,...
...they also use companies based in the EU for services and processing data.